right now when you ask the AI to do
certain things it will not be able to do
it the question is whether it can't do
it or it has been purposely limited by
open AI it's not even connected to the
internet I think they've done that as a
safety measure I think AI is going to be
the revolution of our lifetimes I think
it's going to usher in a golden age at
least for the short term I think it has
the possibility to occur all diseases I
think that's the possibility of helping
us achieve Fusion so that we can
basically eliminate the cost of energy
and here's what's crazy this video was
made entirely by Ai and this is a deep
Vape
I'm just kidding but someday it might be